cnn which is a
i suppose it's a news network of some
sort it's a it's a
fun place run by democrats like don
lemon
and chris cuomo and jake tapper and wolf
blitzer and jim acosta or any of these
people not obviously democrats or any of
these people
obviously not progressives i mean they
all are but they pretend to be
an unbiased news network now you might
say dave but you
tell people about the news you read
stories and share your opinion
and yes i do and i think you fairly well
know my opinion and who i voted for and
why i voted and
what my biases are and perhaps what my
blind spots might be this is
a wonderful thing that we're doing here
that i think is you know ballpark
honest let's put it that way right like
you know what i you know what i think
i really think you you know as much
about what i think about the world
pretty much as i do i really believe
that uh because i'm just telling you
what i think here right and then i can
you can match that up with your own
reality and figure out what's what well
cnn pretends
that it's a news network an unbiased
news network but it's not it's it's a
propaganda wing of the democrat party
and they are really not happy that a
certain amount of americans are not
getting
vaccinated right now again you make a
decision for yourself masks you know my
feelings about all of this stuff okay
and we know again that 97
to 99.5 roughly a percentage of people
who got kovid survived kovid the people
who did not survive had comorbidities
diabetes cancer heart disease a series
of other things
but they really really want you to get
vaccinated on siena and
i'm not exactly sure why i don't want to
be a conspiracy theorist here but we've
got two videos for you we'll
we'll show one this is dr jonathan
reiner on cnn
talking about mandating vaccines
i do think it's time to start mandating
vaccines and i think that private
industry and private organizations will
do that
you know at gw university where i work
uh starting
uh this fall you can't be on campus
unless you're fully vaccinated
look i think that we're in the part of
the pandemic now where
the the problem in this country is that
150 million americans are not vaccinated
now half of that uh number is uh
less than 18 years of age but let's look
at the adults 75 million adults have
chosen not to get vaccinated
and that choice has consequences now we
can't force you to take a jab in the arm
but there are many jobs perhaps that can
prevent you from working if you decide
not to get vaccinated
so i think we need to be more proactive
and i think we will see
uh industry take the lead in this
i mean that should chill it should send
a chill down your spine the
authoritarianism that sits right behind
someone who purports to be a medical
doctor so he's saying 150 million people
aren't vaccinated 75 million of them are
americans and then basically he's
talking about
what the repercussions are if you don't
get vaccinated but notice he didn't
mention the medical repercussions
because he knows if he was to say what
the medical repercussions are if you
don't get vaccinated and by the way i'm
not giving you medical advice
i'm telling you to do what you think you
should do and talk to your doctor about
it
and that's what and that's what you
should do right who am i to tell you
what to do and
who's this tv doctor to tell you what to
do but notice when he says well 75
million americans haven't gotten it
meaning million
adults now the kids it's interesting
because he's saying 75 million kids
haven't got he kind of threw that number
away
he's coming for the kids like they're
obviously coming to
to have man uh vaccine mandates for the
kids for sure but just dealing with
those americans notice when he's talking
about the repercussions
his repercussions are you shouldn't be
able to go to work something's in that
effect he doesn't say what the
repercussions are if you got covered
because if you got coveted most likely
you would then have the antibodies you
would survive and if you didn't have
comorbidities and you weren't of a
certain age and everything else
you would be just fine after that's the
truth
that's the truth but he really really
wants you know where he goes to work at
gw
they're gonna mandate it and that we
should really encourage
other private businesses because maybe
it's unconstitutional
because of right to privacy and all that
maybe it's unconstitutional for the
government to do it so maybe we should
have
private enterprise do it this by the way
is very similar to
when you know people want twitter and
youtube and everybody else the big tech
guys
to crack down on your speech the
government can't quite do it right
you may remember that moment with aoc at
one of the hearings when she was
basically
saying that to zuckerberg hey we can't
do it so why don't you do it which is
the worst sort of
government coercion there is so these
are these are not good people
then we've got video more from cnn the
democratic
operatives at cnn this is former planned
parenthood
president and current cnn medical
contributor
leanna wen for more on vaccines
i think this really depends on what it
is that we do
at this point so now we have this delta
variant that is much more contagious
because it's more contagious it's going
to be even harder for us to reach her
immunity we're going to have to
vaccinate
an even higher proportion of people to
get there what happens then if we end up
having
another variant developing that's even
more contagious that could cause more
disease that could evade the protection
of our immune system
and so how quickly we get this under
control and which way
we go depends on what we do now when it
comes to vaccination
to overcoming disinformation and what we
really need to do at this point is to
make vaccination
the easy choice it needs to be hard for
people to remain unvaccinated
right now it's kind of the opposite it's
fine i mean it's easy if you're
unvaccinated you can do everything you
want to do anyway
but at some point these mandates by
workplaces fight schools
i think it will be important to say hey
you can opt out but if you want to opt
out
you have to sign these forms you have to
get twice weekly testing
basically we need to make getting
vaccinated the easy choice that is what
it's going to take for us to actually
end the pandemic
she wants to really make this impossible
for you to make a medical
decision for yourself uh we she then of
course brings up the delta variant and
guess what there's gonna be an omega
variant
and there's going to be another variant
after that and another one after that
and everything else and then we're gonna
have you're gonna have to sign papers
right we're gonna have to show me your
papers
you have to sign papers we're gonna have
to perhaps put you in camps maybe we
should give you special showers
uh with certain chemicals in those
showers
i mean this all sounds nuts but we are
in a dystopian future and we are in it
right now
and it is a confluence of our corporate
media
our completely psychotic out of control
democrat party
rid you know which is led by a man with
ops
old person syndrome and then these these
doctors that get on
all of these shows who clearly got
nothing right if any of these doctors
got anything right
in the last year and a half then
wouldn't everything be just fine right
now